if you look at some recent polls yes
there continue to be polls in which
Trump is doing very well in the
Republican primary but there are also
polls that are quite close
um and it really depends on which poll
you look at these are Republican primary
polls and Trump is winning depending on
the state or whether it's a general poll
anywhere from between 2 and 28 over Ron
DeSantis but these are not big surges
these are what the numbers have been and
then importantly if you look at the
general election
uh Biden against DeSantis versus Biden
against Trump Biden does better against
Trump in every one of these recent polls